the foreign secretary James cleverley is
in Paris with the Prime Minister and he
joins me now very good morning to you
James cleverley thanks for talking to us
so the government has announced its
latest policy to try to stop small boats
crossing the channel this week what do
you need from this Summit in France for
it to succeed
well obviously illicit migration is an
issue which is facing All European
countries including France and the
French and the British authorities have
already been working together
to prevent as much as possible people
attempting to make that channel crossing
the French authorities have stopped
around half of the attempted Crossings
and through closer coordination uh
greater cooperation we're hoping to be
able to stop more that will be part of
what we discussed today it's worth
bearing in mind of course that the
defense sector is here the environment
sector is here trade ministers are here
so this Summit is about more than just
migration it's about the wide the full
range of anglo-french cooperation but of
course we are looking to work closely
with the French to try and break the
model of these evil people Smugglers who
are making profits from the lives of
others you talk about greater
cooperation does that extend to a
returns deal with France is that
something that you want a deal through
which Britain can return these
cross-channel migrants
well what we are looking to do through
our illegal migration bill is to send
people back to their safe country of
origin there are many many people a very
significant proportion of those people
making illicit or attempting to make you
illicit Channel Crossings who originated
from perfectly safe countries and they
should go there we're also looking to
make uh the uh the application of asylum
in other safe third countries part of it
and of course we will discuss with
France what more we can do but
um this isn't about relying on any one
particular uh element of this this is
about discussing the full range of
international
cooperation between the UK and France to
deal with ultimately
a shared problem between our two
countries
so it sounds like a returns deal isn't
going to happen as a result of this
Summit but will your policy work without
one as you say you've promised to remove
those entering on small boats within 28
days Rwanda hasn't proved an option so
far and if a deal can't be done with our
closest neighbor where are these
migrants really going to go
well uh I personally and my officials in
the fcdo have been negotiating with
countries around the world about returns
agreements and of course you've got to
remember that the people on the French
Coast getting to small boats uh did not
originate in France so we are looking at
ways of of
um sending people back to Safe countries
from which they originated
um and we continue we had a successful
uh decision in the courts about our
Rwanda scheme and we will be looking at
returning people to Safe third countries
or their own country of origin But
ultimately whatever response we come up
with and it will require a mixer of
responses we we you know your your
viewers should recognize that all this
needs to be done in international with
International cooperation that's what
this Summit is about that's the
conversations that I've been having with
other countries around the world and we
will continue you to put a real focus on
this issue which we know is at the
Forefront of many many people's minds
real focus and quite a lot of money as
well is involved isn't it Britain's
given France money to help stop these
Crossing through various deals will
France be getting more money will there
be a new deal and how long might that
deal cover
well the the precise details of how we
operationalize how we turn this uh joint
focus into processes is part of what
we're discussing today and I don't want
to to speculate what the outcome of
those negotiations uh between the Prime
Minister and president macron uh will be
but we we have been working with the
French including uh UK part funding some
of the French activities on the North
Coast of uh France that has enabled
France to as I say prevent around half
of the attempted
Crossings uh and so this is a model that
has proved uh its Effectiveness we want
to make it even more effective still and
of course we will be negotiating about
what uh the the funding of additional
work by the French authorities in the
French Coast will be but as I say I
don't want to I don't want to kind of
speculate about live negotiations that
we'll be conducting today
this is the first summit with France
since 2018 five years ago do you regret
that do you think that unnecessary
damage has been done to the relationship
by the last two prime ministers
well we've got to remember that uh in
that intervening period of time we have
had a
um delays because of the general
election we have a hung Parliament we
had a general election uh we had covid
so there's been a number of things which
have uh which have disrupted the ability
to have this joint Summit it's a big
event a number of uh senior British
ministers will be here having meetings
with their French counterparts
um but it is worth bearing in mind that
we have been coordinating very very
closely with the French government the
French authorities and a whole range of
areas notwithstanding the fact we've not
had a formal Summit I speak with my
French counterpart not quite on a weekly
basis but I mean certainly many many
times a month and we find ourselves in
in close agreement on a number of really
big issues including for example Ukraine
self-defense against Russian aggression
about the nature of shifting doing
balances of international trade and a
whole range of issues so of course it's
great that we've got this Summit it's a
really really good way of driving for
the bilateral relationship but we have
been working closely with the French uh
authorities and the French government
for some time anyway the last prime
minister Liz truss couldn't decide if
president macron was a friend or Foe was
that regrettable well look uh the uh you
know France is our our nearest neighbor
a close Ally a good friend the November
of last year I was invited to attend uh
the French
Armistice Day commemorations we have a
closeness an intimacy of relationship
between the UK and France which is
perhaps unlike many around the world
um and of course we're very very proud
of the fact that
um economically in terms of defense and
a whole load of areas France and the UK
remain very very close partners and
Friends
okay well James cleverley foreign
secretary thanks very much indeed for
your time this morning ahead of those
meetings we appreciate it